welcome everybody uh you all know that i
have no interest whatsoever no intention
whatsoever no motivation whatsoever
to deceive you about the believability
or the trustworthiness of anybody but in
particular in the context of the january
6 committee investigating the trump
riots i have no interest in telling you
that a witness is any more or less
credible than they actually are and in a
few minutes we're going to look at a
specific claim made by former aide to
former trump chief of staff mark meadows
cassidy hutchinson we're going to look
at a specific claim she made that's
being disputed
and we will discuss is this plausible
who do we think is telling the truth
we're going to look at that and she may
have
said something that wasn't true
we'll figure it out
but
first we have to talk about these brazen
and completely baseless smears that have
launched against cassidy hutchinson and
it's a really great insight into how a
propaganda outlet
in this case breitbart the right-wing
propaganda outlet breitbart can generate
what looks like a news story based on
nothing
headline from this morning breitbart
report cassidy hutchinson fabricated
testimony about conversation with former
white house counsel pat chipoloni
whoa report this must be pretty serious
you start reading the article and you
will very quickly see what this is about
the article reads cassidy hutchinson a
former white house aide who was the
january 6th committee star witness
during a surprise hearing
held on tuesday
reportedly fabricated pieces of her
testimony about conversations she had
with former white house counsel patricia
bologna okay
during her testimony hutchinson claimed
that chipoloni told her to tell her boss
chief of staff mark meadows that former
president trump should not go to the
capitol on january 6th that's true she
did testify to that hutchinson testified
chipoloni said we're going to get
charged with every crime imaginable if
trump went to the capitol
the committee's vice chair liz cheney
doubled down on her calls to get
tripoloni to testify before the
committee due to hutchinson's testimony
as we heard yesterday white house
counsel pat chipoloni had significant
concerns about trump's activities on
january 6th cheney tweeted it's time for
mr chipoloni to testify on the record
any concerns he has about the
institutional interests of his prior
office are outweighed by the need for
his testimony that's true they are now
they have now subpoenaed pat chipoloni
and we will get to that but then it
starts to get a little weird the
breitbart article reads however
chipoloni was reportedly not at the
white house on the morning of january
6th
according to human events senior editor
jack posobiac uh-oh
and then you look what is the source of
this report and it is tweets from a
conspiracy theorist jack posobiac
that's the source
jack posobiac tweeted
apropos of nothing citing no sources
breaking multiple sources including one
who was at the white house on january 6
tell me
chipoloni was not there in the am when
hutchinson testified she spoke with him
january 6 committee is aware of this
discrepancy and are ignoring media
inquiries about it seems she made up the
entire conversation
okay
this is an example of the collapse of
journalism now remember i don't do
journalism i do commentary i'm not a
reporter okay and so when i tell you
where am i getting a story
i tell you i'm getting this from a news
reporting agency
or i'm getting this from an opinion
person or whatever the case may be
breitbart claims to be doing news and
reporting
and when you look
they are just citing a tweet
from a conspiracy theorist
that's it that's the whole basis
anybody who has worked at an actual
journalism institution would know
there are standards and practices and no
serious journalism outfit would publish
such a story
based on a tweet from a conspiracy
theorist that's all it is that's all
that this is there's nothing there
there's just nothing there
and when
someone in trump's orbit
is trying to
gather information to discredit a
witness
and everybody's insisting on anonymity
and none of them actually show up to
testify under oath and maybe some of
them will and then i'll change my
perspective
when you publish something like this
you are you are becoming a node
or in a signal booster of disinformation
and by the way it's disinformation all
in the service of defending and running
interference for those who tried to
convert completely subvert
the democracy of the united states but i
guess it generates clicks i don't know
now
if secret service wants to testify under
oath
whatever if they want to do that then
let's listen to them and then we will
have two competing under oath statements
to evaluate and compare
okay
right now
we have the under oath testimony of
cassidy hutchinson
and then we have you know unsourced
tweets
vague statements about we would be
willing to dispute elements of her
testimony but nobody's actually shown up
under oath despite being invited by the
january 6 committee
so that's what this is this is pond scum
now let's get to a more substantive
claim about something cassidy hutchinson
said which is being uh
contradicted specifically and narrowly
one of our sponsors is magic spoon the
only breakfast cereal that tastes
exactly like your favorite sugary
childhood cereals but with zero sugar
only four net carbs and 14 grams of
protein so if you're just generally
trying to keep your sugar intake
relatively low like me or if you're
doing low carb if you're doing keto
you can enjoy the sweet nostalgic snack
without the sugar in flavors like cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter cookies and
cream maple waffle blueberry cinnamon
they've just added honey nut to their
permanent collection i love magic spoon
our whole team does and they've been
supporting the show for years how about
this if you try magic spoon and you
don't think it's amazing like we do
they'll give you your money back because
magic spoon stands behind their product
because it's that good you really can't
tell it apart from the classic cereals
build your own custom variety pack
you'll get five dollars off when you go
to magic spoon dot com slash pacman and
use the promo code pacman the link is in
the description